hello everyone and welcome back to the
air things masters we are in the
knockout phase of the tournament after
three days of the preliminaries uh
four players had to drop out auto
determined and here
in the uh quarterfinals we have magnus
carlsen versus daniel dubose so the
master faces the the student and
already we have a very exciting game so
without further ado let's check it out
everything is the same in the in
tournament the time format is the same
and uh the games can only get more and
more interesting
so without further ado magnus with the
white pieces
opens with e4 uh with e5 from duboff not
going for the sicilian this game
knight to f3 that's not a knight knight
to c6 and
bishop to b5 so magnus goes for the
royal lopez
with a6 morphy's defense and the bishop
to a4 so this is all
i've been this has all been played uh
thousands of times
uh knight to f6 d3 and now
b5 attacking that bishop uh with bishop
back to b3 and bishop to c5 sort of an
anderson variation of morphy's defense
uh we have c3 later on you can advance
the pawn to d4
also you you can hide this bishop to c2
if needed
and do both strikes in the center with
d5 so
uh what do you do here uh magnus first
captures once we have captures captures
and now
magnus just castles here do both castles
as well
and rook to e1 and now there's a double
attack on this e5 pawn
and there is one game in the database
where bishop to g4 was played kind of
makes sense as you don't want to allow
knight captures on e5
but dooba being doable uh he plays
bishop to e6 instead
and he offers the e5 pawn now can you
capture the e5 pawn
of course not because if you capture it
obviously you don't capture with the
rook because then you just lose material
but if you capture with the knight
it's not much better because bishop
captures on f2 with check
this is what dubo had in mind and after
king captures just
knight captures on e5 after rook
captures an e5 queen f6
check picks up the rook so obviously not
the greatest idea for white
so magnus instead just continues
developing he did uh consider the
position for
quite a bit uh he played knight b to d2
afterwards
and now comes knight to f4 uh we have d4
by magnus because the d3 pawn is under
attack
twice from the knight and the queen so
uh he takes advantage of this knight
uh being only defended by this e5 pawn
and he defends it with the d4 and now
this works for him
e captures on d4 and now knights the e4
by magnus with
a double attack on the knight here and
under bishop on c5
this is how he wins back his material uh
problem is for magnus he's already down
to seven minutes and 30 seconds whereas
duboff is
almost up to full time he's around 14
minutes and some seconds so here uh both
of these pieces are attacked
so bishop d6 defending uh sorry about
that
defending the knight and now magnus just
grabs back his pawn so c
captures on the e4 and here dubo uh does
some trading first bishop captures on b3
queen captures on b3 and
now rook to e8 uh just
developing this rook to a nice open e
file bishop captures an f4 by magnus
with bishop captures
and now rook 8 to d1 and magnus has
completed his development
uh asking duba what do you play here and
dubo goes for queen to d7 he develops
the queen the rooks are now connected
uh as they say in pogchamps they've
become bros for life and here comes
knight to c5 for magnus
now the queen is under attack and also
there's some pressure on this a6 pawn
and here
duval can choose to just trade for
example captures captures and then
bring the queen over to f5 which is
perfectly fine but he decides to
offer a pawn to magnus by playing queen
to f5
right away and now as you can see the a6
pawn is very weak
you can either capture on e8 allow
capture and then capture the a6 pawn
or you can do it the way magnus did it
just capture the pawn right away
so knight captures on a6 and here uh
dual just goes back
bishop to d6 and now what can magnus do
here
magnus brings back the knight knight to
c5 and now do both trades rook capture
sunny one
rook capture sunny one and now knight
captures on d4 this was dubois idea we
have knight captures on d4
and the queen captures on c5 now so
magnus needs to grab one more pawn
otherwise uh this was all for nothing
and the situation on the clock is uh um
well very favorable for dubo it's four
minutes for magnus
uh sorry is very favorable for magnus
here dubo was extremely low on time
magnus was four minutes on the clock
whereas do both had only 10 seconds on
the clock but as it is a rapid
tournament you get
10 seconds every time you make a move so
here do both quickly
after carlson grabbed the pawn here
duboff played
bishop to e5 now and magnus just brought
back the knight and now you have this
very weird position where magnus already
has a past a pawn
he's a a lot better on time and duba
needs to make a move because the clock
is ticking in he's constantly surviving
on those extra 10 seconds he makes when
he makes a move
so here although a lot of moves are
possible maybe bishop to d4
for example going after the f2 pawn uh
he just grabs uh the
knight on c3 saying he will hold the end
game
uh as uh there will be a lot less uh you
know
possibilities for magnus to to go for so
here be captures on c3
you could also capture with the queen
but then it's just too easy for duboff
to draw this
king of f8 you prevent the the checkmate
and now rookie two defending
again you have to play this end game
being down upon but you will probably
be able to hold it so here instead after
bishop captures on c3
we have b captures in c3 by magnus and
now
g6 getting rid of any back rank
weaknesses because after the rook moves
you don't want to
get checkmated and now magnus starts
pushing his past pawn with a4
and now rook to d8 by dubaf uh we have
queen to c2 dubo wants to bring the rook
to d2 and then uh well
sort of uh checkmate magnus here with
queen f2 so queen c2 preventing
the uh rook lift and now king to g7
uh with g3 magnus also creates some
breeding room for his king
and rook to d6 now preparing rook f6
again to go after the f2
pawn so rook to e3 magnus blocks the
queen
this way also adds additional protection
to the e3 pawn
and now queen to d5 and now
it's a bit of a bit of a dangerous
battery adobo has here so magnus
well he could opt for some moves like h3
or h4 magnus goes for the queen trade
immediately and he will now
uh try to torture dubo as much as he can
in this uh well sort of equalish rook
end game
but it's uh uh like i said very hard
with such a little so little time on the
clock
so here duke of ken uh declined the
queen queen queen trade but he decides
to trade captures captures and now rook
c6 he wants to
uh grab the c3 pawn and magnus says okay
i'm going to continue pushing my own
past pawn
so double grabs on c3 and now rook to a4
you always have to put a rook behind the
pass pawn and now you have to push that
pass pawn so double's
next few moves are a must he needs to
stop that past pawn
rook b3 a6 by magnus rook to b8
uh you have to play like this and now
you could push a7 right away
magnus first starts by improving the
position of his king king f1
king to f6 and king to e2 we have king
to e6
king to d3 now king to d5 blocking
uh uh carlson's king from advancing
further up the board
and now rook to d4 check king to c6 and
now
rook to c4 with check king d6 and now
rook to f4 going after the f7 pawn
do both defense and the magnus goes back
rook to d4 with
king c6 and rook to c4 with check and
now there's no clear way of how to look
for advantage here magnus just uh needs
to try and
wear out do of as he he he tries to get
him as low on time as possible
so here came back to d6 king the d for
now
magnus against some more squares for his
king and now
rook to a8 dubo goes after the pass pawn
rook to a4 magnus defends it and again
king back to c6 with
rook back to a2 and king to b6 now and
here magnus just goes king
king to d5 the problem for dubo is he
can never capture this pawn
because if captures captures and
captures king the c6 just
wins the game for magnus he will win the
pawn next
and then just shift his king over there
grab all of the pawns and
that's just the game so instead we have
brooke the d8 to check by do both kinked
at e6 and now comes
rook back to a8 we have rook to b2 check
now
asking do you want to go back king to c6
which probably would have been a safer
option for double but dubai
decides that it's actually okay to
capture the pawn which is
which it is only it's a bit more
complicated to play
so carlson goes back king to d5 and now
rook to e8 uh preparing to either defend
the pawn or
try and harass the white king from
behind here king the c6
trying to uh well checkmate dubo with
rook to a2 because if the pawn is
defended and rook to a2 is checkmate
of course dubo will not fall for that
that's why he played rook to e8 he
checks carlson's king
rook to e6 with check and now carlson
picks up the pawn and again the material
on the board is still completely
equal uh but duboff's king completely
cut off from the board
uh with this rook on the b file so here
dubo tries
f4 he wants to trade off some of the
piece some of the pawns here on the king
side
so it would be much easier to hold the
draw but magnus goes king d7
attacks his rook rook back to e1 and now
uh not trading or anything like that you
could grab a pawn here but then you'd
have doubled f pawns
and it'd be much easier for the black
rook to pick them off one by one so here
g4 by magnus now saying that if rook the
h1 which was played in the game uh you
could defend it with
a move like f3 then the
uh the h pawn will be defended by the
rook but magnus first goes king to c6
he finds a very sneaky plan now again
threatening checkmate
do both defense with king to a5 with
king c5 again threatening checkmate
king a4 and now uh magnus finds rook to
be for
with check this is how magnus picks up
the f4 pawn without
ruining his pawn structure so king a3
and now
rook captures on f4 we have rook
captures and h2 material
still completely equal and now uh rook
back to f7 now
magnus will start pushing the f pawn and
try and create a past
f pawn and the duval can at any point
push h5 and create a pass pawn of his
own first he starts improving the
position of his king
king b3 with f4 by magnus
king to c3 now the king is in a much
better position than when he was
on a3 but magnus still pushes with a
with f5 with g captures g captures and
f5 by magnus now both of them with past
pawns
and here uh dubo needs to play very
precise moves uh for example
uh we're just going to show one line
that works for him king to d3
for example king d5 king e3 king e5 and
now king to f3
will allow duboff to hold this position
for example f6 you're going to play rook
h5
check king to kick the king away king to
d6 now king to f4
and after rook to c7 making room for the
pawn to be pushed just rook f5
and now you're guarding this pawn and
you're gonna start pushing your own pawn
for example f7
uh you're gonna play h5 and now after
king here preparing to
queen the pawn you can just give up the
rook and now of course
uh white will also have to give up uh
for example his
uh his rook to stop your pawn at some
point uh like this
i don't really it's uh it can go either
way but at some point white will also
have to give it up
so here king the d3 a viable option for
for dobov
however duo played rooked a2 instead
and now it simply doesn't work so feel
free to pause the video
and win this game for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding either
of the two winning moves uh or
rather even more of them uh king the d5
is winning the f6 right away is winning
and even the rook to f8 is winning so
a lot of moves are winning here for
magnus because rook to a2 was such a
sub-optimal move that uh pretty much any
move you made was winning in this
position so congratulations to everyone
so king to d5 was the move that magnus
chose and now we have
rook to a5 checked by do both king to e4
and now rook to a for check king e5 and
now
duo started pushing his pass pawn but uh
now it's uh
it's a much different position than the
one that we've shown the king and rook
are much much further away than in the
variation that we've shown so
h4 f6 we have rook the a5 with
czech king e6 rookie rook a6 check king
f5
rook to a5 check and now king to g6 and
now
rook to a4 again defending the pawn here
by the just
f7 by magnus we have rook to g4 check
king to f5 and now rook to g1
preparing to i play rook to f1 check for
example if you're not careful you bring
a queen into the game rook f1 check king
has to move and now you pick up the
queen
should will result in a draw so here
instead after this rook the g1 move uh
we have
rook capture sun h4 the simplest way to
win the game
and it was in this position on move 72
that daniel dubo resigned the game and
the game one goes to magnus carlsen so
we'll see if dubuf can get back
into this match and will he be able to
retaliate at some point here of course
you resign because after rook to f1
check you just block
and regardless of what black plays you
bring the queen into the game on your
next move
so really a great game to start off
their match
dual playing again in great style
beautiful opening beautiful
uh that bishop to e6 move was really
exciting uh offering magnus
to make a mistake such early on in the
game but magnus was
able to take it into an end game and
then uh with the dub of having little
time on the clock uh
you know he he defended perfectly but
magnus will just drag it on drag it on
drag it on
and magnus knows that you will make a
mistake before he does that's that's how
magnus rolls
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game sure uh
hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i'm sure dubo hasn't but you know
there are more games
in the match uh i would like to thank
andrew martin and michael castano
luis souza paul sampson and mativ granda
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the air things masters checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day